a must-see series
premiering thursday august 18th new
marvel hero love that all new night
let's do this she hulk attorney at law
original series streaming thursday august 18th
only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this
will be my new she-hulk trailer video there's
a whole bunch of new footage obviously teasing
the abomination plot there's a whole bunch of
daredevil stuff going on so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes so be sure to
subscribe to get everything i'll do a special
marvel giveaway in all my she-hulk videos
too because it'll be starting really soon
the other big reminder in this trailer to make
another smart hulk reference marvel has chosen the
smart way the way of peace and move she-hulk in
andor episodes so that they're not on the same day
star wars and or episodes will be on wednesdays
and she-hulk episodes will be on thursday so
that's the order that my videos will post in
when they start overlapping but they make a
lot of jokes about her balancing her two different
lives now after she gets her powers like she wants
to continue doing all the normal things that she
does when she was jennifer walters like her dating
life like she's on this fast track she's this
well-respected lawyer but then she gets dosed with
the hulk's blood and gets the powers of the hulk
becomes she-hulk and wants to continue living that
life that's why you have all those scenes with the
hulk trying to train her saying no no no you have
all these powers now you have a responsibility
people are going to be coming for you people
like thunderbolt ross like val the thunderbolts
are going to want you they're going to want to
take your powers and use them to their own ends
but at this point early in the series she's not
thinking about any of that she's like no no i have
this really really demanding job people respect me
for i'm earning a ton of money doing that i want
to keep doing that and then continually throughout
the series you just see a bunch of different
events happen villains like abomination having to
defend him all these other villains like daredevil
who is also a lawyer and a superhero by night
forcing her to realize that she does have a
responsibility like she can be a superhero
and have this life as a lawyer too i mean really
daredevil is probably the best example of that
like oh yeah you can do both things just don't
expect to have the normal life that you had before
like your dating life is going to get a little bit
weird like you have all these jokes about death by
snooze new this character arthur here he's called
arthur in the series so i'll explain who i think
that he is he might be playing a version of a
comic book character from the she-hulk comics
but they have all these jokes about him just
choosing death by smash like he just really
wants him some of that thick she-hulk what'd they
die of crushed pelvises computer sentences then
to death by snooze new yeah yeah thick with two
c's because she's like six foot seven i believe
during the trailer if you know tatiana maslany
in real life she is tiny that's kind of the way
the powers of the hulk work like it depends on
how tall you were before you got the powers of
the hook when you get those game abilities it
just proportionately grows you bigger so for
instance thor is way taller than bruce banner
when they're just like in normal human form if
thor got the powers of the hulk the game abilities
he would be a much bigger version of a hulk than
the bruce banner hulk the other big thing they
confirmed during this is what's going on with
the abomination during the course of the series so
tim roth has found a way to go back into tim roth
form like human form in the comics abomination
doesn't have the ability to go back into human
form so that is a little bit of a difference but
what they're doing is they're trying to make it
sort of like a dark parallel for what happened
with the bruce banner hulk during the mcu movies
so after incredible hulk the last time you saw
them fight each other they obviously recast the
hulk but through all the avengers movies through
thor ragnarok all the movies he's been in avengers
endgame eventually he slowly became more zen and
formed a better balance between his two different
personalities so that he can form the professor
hulk version of his character technically he's
supposed to be a little bit weaker but i think in
the mcu they're saying he's just as powerful as he
was when he was full hulk like he launches the
boulder into outer space literally so it seems
like they're trying to say that the abomination
has been on the same path in the mcu while he's
been locked up this whole time in that special
cell like he's been trying to become more zen but
i think part of the idea because we all expect him
to be in the thunderbolts movie for val to recruit
him have some kind of cameo scene during she-hulk
where she's like i'm gonna offer you a deal
time off your sentence if you join my team early
theory is that he's just pretending to be zen
peddling this new age mythology that he's
trying to sell to everyone just to earn money
and find a way to get out of prison like he's just
pretending to be zen during the she-hulk trailers
jennifer walters boss at her law firm tells
her that they're forming a superhero division
and her new job now is to defend the abomination
so she literally has to find a way to free him
from prison even though he's done all this stuff
it's a bit of a joke on lawyers like oh yeah you
have to represent this terrible villain character
so it's kind of them clowning on lawyers saying
that like lawyers are just as bad as super
villains because of the things that they do
they have all these scenes where she goes to
this self-help group that he's leading where
he's trying to tell them to be all said like no
no we don't get crazy like that calm down everyone
you see all these other super powered individuals
some of them look like mutants i'll explain who
some of these characters are because some of them
are from the daredevil comics which makes sense
because there's so much daredevil happening during
the series but like you look in the background
you see this abomaste sign that sounds like the
new age zen stuff that he's peddling to everyone
selling to everyone in these classes and it's
just to play on his abomination name it looks
like they have a swear jar in the background here
with all these symbols of buddhism and eastern
religions around it like i said he's peddling all
this new age mythology to them it looks like the
special meetings that he's holding here are
also happening at this special country club
because in the outdoor scenes you see her in the
same dress with her complimenting her butt like
your butt looks so good right now this will be
like one of the horniest marvel series you've ever
seen since the loki series between loki getting
it on with a version of himself and everybody
wanting to get it on with the thicker version of
she-hulk no king shaming here you also notice in
these outdoor scenes at this country club place
you see a version of titania's character in indoor
you also see her at these same meeting scenes but
there's also a lot of behind the scenes where you
see holes in the walls and like crazy stuff going
on so it sounds like somebody at the meeting winds
up losing it and things get really crazy you
also see a lot of scenes in the courtroom where
she goes after she-hulk and she has to hulk out
and they just go at it but i believe the death
by snooze new character here who they're calling
arthur might be a version of arthur moore who was
in her comics wasn't the she-hulk comics he was a
magic-based villain who used a special talisman to
rob banks and do a bunch of other shady stuff
he also got into it with jennifer walters in
court and tried to get her disbarred by getting
her to hulk out during one of the trials these
two characters that they keep showing in all the
trailers seem like versions of matador and man
bull who are both from the daredevil comics which
makes sense like i said because daredevil's such a
big part of the series matador is just a really
skilled fighter and as the name implies he's a
professional bullfighter on the side he doesn't
have any special powers though his real name is
manuel elganto manvol as the name implies is a
minotaur he's half man half bull his only real
superpower other than the transformation process
is that he has enhanced strength and durability
he was born as a regular human though and mutated
by a special serum that he was given during
experiments so technically you think of him as a
mutate but like we're seeing more and more mutants
pop up in the mcu so you could call him a mutant
so in the way that monica rambo's dna was mutated
and that's how she got her powers you could
also think of them as mutants just in general
the comics are really technical about who you
can call a mutant and what happens to people
like spider-man who have biological powers but
get them in different ways later in life like
spider-man is called to mutate because he got his
powers from the spider bite that mutated his dna
and just in general it seems like during marvel
phase four they're trying to introduce more
and more mutant characters in general like during
the miss marvel series they literally tell her
that she is a mutant and they play the x-men the
animated series theme song wanting you to think
more and more about mutants popping up i think
part of the arc with abomination during the series
is that because jennifer walters has to just come
to terms with the idea that she has to defend him
even though she knows about their history during
the incredible hulk movie like he tried to kill my
cousin even though it's a joke about the edward
norton version of hulk she eventually does her
best to try and be a lawyer like she wants to and
defend him even though he is this terrible person
but he'll probably reveal himself or do something
super shady and she'll find a way with some help
from like daredevil wong or even the bruce banner
version of hulk to try and get him thrown back in
prison wherein we'll probably see val show
up and say okay well you're back in prison
now your only way out is to make a deal with
me and i'll give you time off your sentence
we're putting together a squad no it is not called
the suicide squad because that would be copyright
infringement thunderbolts in the mcu is kind
of like their version of a suicide squad team
where you have a bunch of anti-heroes and people
from prison like super villains who get time off
their sentence or get their sentences commuted by
being on the team if you look at the marvel phase
5 schedule 2 they're introducing characters
like agatha harkness a bunch of other super
villain characters through the different series it
seems like they're going to slowly fill out that
thunderbolts team with a lot of these different
projects but i think we already have assumptions
about some of the characters on the team like
during falcon and winter soldier baron zemo and
john walker u.s agent definitely going to be on
that team probably elena bolova's black widow
maybe ghost obviously abomination probably gonna
be on the team maybe taskmaster 2 we'll see about
taskmaster and then because we have the agatha
harkness series maybe act of the hardness is also
on a version of the team there's really no hard
and fast rule about how big the team roster has
to be like they'll probably have jokes about
killing off members that are lesser and then
bringing in new members during the movie kind
of the same way that they did during the suicide
squad movies like in james gunn's suicide squad
film they literally killed off like a whole team
at the beginning of that film just to have a joke
about how expendable they are it'll probably be
a similar situation during the thunderbolts movie
but everyone posts all your theories about what's
going on with some of these bigger characters
like what do you think abomination is doing
during the she-hulk series what do you think the
daredevil is going to be doing during the series
i've already explained what's going on with wong's
character during the series and why he's showing
up so i had a link for that video at the end of
this too big reminder my episodes will start next
week so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss those they're also doing
a special disney plus day next month where they'll
be releasing a whole bunch of trailers it'll be
like trailer fest for all the big marvel disney
plus series that are coming up of course i'll
do videos for all the footage that they wind up
releasing it'll be really cool speaking of brand
new stuff i literally just did a first look video
at the new ironheart series we just got a teaser
click here to learn all about that and click here
for my other she-hulk daredevil trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!